what would happen do you do that thing
where you put your hand on the hand on
the dart board and you hope your buddy
misses it no we would turn out the
lights in the basement and everybody get
two darts and they could just whip him
whatever Direction you wanted to that it
was a different time dude it was a
different time I
you wa you know listen we were it was it
was maybe we were unsupervised you know
that's more than
unsupervised it wasn't dude you could
have killed somebody yeah yeah mhm
but did anybody any catastrophic
injuries no catastrophic injuries did
you generally miss each other except for
once and that was the end of that game
who got hit uh and and where right in
the shoulder o so the all the walls were
wood okay wood boards so you would hear
when you threw the dart and you missed
you would hear GK yeah yeah yeah yeah GK
cuz it's stuck into the wood yeah yeah
yeah but every now and then it would hit
like a couch or yeah but flesh made a
different sound